[Music]
hey guys I hope you're all having a
great day for this fourth installment of
Harry Potter theory we're going to be
covering a topic that I saw requested in
the comment section quite a bit and that
is what are the Dementors and where did
they come from
I chose this topic because they are
never really properly explained but our
so prominent throughout what are they
I'll start off by expanding what
Dementors are and discuss their general
function in the Harry Potter universe
the mentors were originally created by
JK Rowling as a way of representing
depression Rowling in response to an
interview question about Dementors being
representations of depression had to say
this yes that is exactly what they are
it was entirely conscious and entirely
from my own experience depression is the
most unpleasant thing I have ever
experienced it is that absence of being
able to end visage that you will ever be
cheerful again the absence of hope that
very deadened feeling which is so very
different from feeling sad sad hurts but
it's a healthy feeling it's a necessary
thing to feel depression is very
different
I think the mentors are the scariest
things I've written with that being said
the actual definition of a Dementor is
fairly abstract and what they actually
are can be articulated in many ways my
favorite way to define the mentor is
this the mentors are three metres tall
with dark race gabi skin they're often
cloaked and it is often hard to get a
proper look at them the mentors are the
foul list of the foul they represent
despair unhappiness hopelessness
loneliness
you name it the mentors will suck out
your soul and leave you with no trace of
happiness or hope if they have their way
with you every good feeling in memory
will be entirely gone they are infamous
for their kiss which is the act of
sucking the soul out of the body
provided they're successful in kissing
you the heart of the target will stop
pumping blood and the brain will die
they are known as the chief inhabitants
of Azkaban and guard the prison fortress
now I'll leave it to Silas to explain
where they come from now that we have a
good grasp of what they are I will
attempt to first explain where they come
from and then explain how they're
created this has never been definitively
lamed in the Harry Potter universe so I
will try my best to go with what is most
canonically consistent for whatever
reason Dementors are inextricably tied
to the island of Azkaban Azkaban is of
course where all witches and wizards who
break the rules of the Wizarding World
are banished the original inhabitant of
Azkaban was a wizard called a Christus a
Kris dis built a fortress on the island
and was extremely powerful known to
practice in the worst kind of dark arts
he was infamous for luring muggle
sailors to his Island then torturing and
murdering them this made the island the
perfect environment for the original
conception of Dementors there is
speculation that while stewing on the
island by himself he created the
Dementors when a Kris diss a band in
Azkaban the fortress that he had created
became a home to continually breeding
two Mentors while we do not have a
proper explanation for how the original
Dementor was created there are some
feasible explanations for how they breed
and multiply there are two equally valid
theories about how Dementors reproduce
with the chief difference as being that
one side argues that Dementors grow like
fungus and the other side arguing that
Dementors do in fact breed the first
theory is that dimensions do not breed
so to speak but rather grow under
conditions of despair degradation
hopelessness unhappiness and darkness
the greater the concentration of these
conditions the more Dementors will
appear if the environment is entirely
absent of hope you can guarantee that
the Dementors will be there in abundance
the second theory is a little more vague
but this partial explanation comes
straight from the mouth of fudge who in
the half-blood prince mentioned that the
Dementors were breeding and suggested
that their breeding was the cause of all
the mist that was present from this we
can infer that a Dementors breed while
in large quantities be Dementors do in
fact breed and see their breeding
generates a sort of mist with that being
said I'd like to hear what you guys have
to
say on this topic the lack of
information surrounding Dementors is
intriguing and it leaves the topic very
much up to our own interpretations do
you guys agree with the theories that I
mentioned above or is there something
that I'm missing with that I bid you
farewell and remember help will always
be given at Hogwarts to those who ask
for it
[Music]